hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
so male Monday July 25th 2016 what's
going on how what's going on
the final Monday in July of 2016 and old
freckles old Billy red beard Oh [ __ ]
Billy fat face looking trying to get the
weight off yeah I'm trying to get the
weight off working out during the day
great having a beer at night [ __ ]
losing everything that he worked for
it's [ __ ] ridiculous it's ridiculous
what one beer does and I just I got to
do it I got a bunch of beers left over
from the [ __ ] fourth of July they're
takin up all this space in my fridge and
I'm not going to throw them out I mean
there's children that work in the
Budweiser factory that [ __ ] you know
they sleep on piles of hay right they
pay them 29 cents a month I don't know
if that's true maybe it's hops I don't
know what they sleep on now there's no
people there's no children there's no
children working at Budweiser that's but
Peyton Manning wouldn't invest in
Budweiser there was children there I'm
just going to go give me a couple
Budweiser
we had protection issues my watts on
steroids wasn't me she blew out her
shoulder making s'mores so she has human
growth hormones right all I'm going to
say about that before I put my balls on
somebody's head I'm sorry
believe in an ottoman a great mood
yeah so I got these [ __ ] I got all
these bears in my fridge one of my good
what am I talking my supposed to do with
my kids roam out I got Boddingtons I got
some millas so I just have like one a
night right and then I have a home pour
of [ __ ] whiskey that's all she wrote
that's all she wrote I barely even get
buzzed off of that too when I wake up
the next day and I just feel like [ __ ] I
don't know why I keep doing it it's a
habit I have to break
I am a I am a one-and-a-half drink
alcoholic I have to have one and a half
drinks and get a little buzzed every
night I want to go to a [ __ ] a a
meeting and say like that's my problem
you know I never forget one instead of
going off the rails when I uh yeah I
would have I'd have won mellow light
tall in a can and then I'd have a home
porter of whiskey and of course after I
finished that I would just stop and I'd
go to sleep and the next day I'd wake up
and I'd be totally functional and I'd go
to work but I you know I'd definitely be
a little grouchy and now that's my story
okay
thank you for sharing this guy comes up
my uncle right there was a twelve-foot
always right they throw me out of there
may be walking up put down am doughnuts
I don't know why they all have southern
accents in my world everyone in a is
from the south you know why they never
got over the war this don't fight it
down there South's going to rise again
and do what you're going to secede from
the union you're going to get old
Stonewall Jackson jr. jr. jr. yeah yeah
to come back and take over for you you
know what I say to that I say good luck
dice a good [ __ ] them you know do it
just know this you can't have Florida if
you can't have Florida and you can't go
to California where you're going to take
your kids huh
when they say you know when they did
[ __ ] sitting there watching your
Confederate TV right and it's a small
world comes on which is even more
apropos however the [ __ ] you say it
because you just like nine [ __ ]
states down there whatever the hell you
are right it's a small world after all
and they're like you would they call
fathers down in uh or the way they color
Bennett yo Jim dad I want to go to
Disneyworld you can't because you
seceded from the Union you can't go to
Disneyland and you can't go to his
[ __ ] world you know what you can go
Talladega you can go see the Winston Cup
Series how they got a waterslide
out there I don't think they do they got
of a bunch of adults skip it around and
[ __ ] outfits that scare children
they do not so let me tell you something
[ __ ] there Mason diction Mason and
diction
why don't you think twice think about
everything you're going to lose out on a
few seceded from the Union huh
no more Disneyland no more Disneyworld
SeaWorld's down there you don't get to
see those [ __ ] fish that don't want
to be there yeah a lot of people think
like fish like don't give a [ __ ] that
they're in a tank you know just because
they don't have an ability to speak to
us that therefore that means they have
depth fine with it we treat fish like
immigrants you know the fish is [ __ ]
looking at you you just like speak
English you got a problem with that hey
sit at [ __ ] sit there staring at me
guys on the side of your [ __ ] scaly
head be happy I didn't eat you you look
at me one more time I'll cut your
[ __ ] head off I'll roll you in some
flour with an egg wash and I'll deep-fry
you [ __ ] and I'll make your
friends watch sit there and [ __ ]
stare at me like I work for you I don't
work for you who here is going to say
that's right I didn't say so I didn't
say so anyways bill why you so off the
[ __ ] wall today you know why because
I wrapped at least the scriptwriting
part of season two of efforts or family
which means I get to go back to being a
[ __ ] 14 year old who has no job no
responsibilities no nothing just a bunch
of beers in my fridge that I'm slowly
going to kill I do the elliptical in the
morning and then I give it all back with
a can of beer and that's what I do right
while I [ __ ] wear out my joint that's
all I'm really doing right now I'm just
maintaining
isn't that what a lot of people in this
digital age you're just trying to do why
aren't they just trying to maintain just
trying to keep their heads above water
in this time of change and robots is it
big [ __ ] does the election is that
happened yet
Jesus [ __ ] you go near the goddamn TV
everybody's so [ __ ] scared oh it's
going to happen nothing is going to
continue on the way it's supposed to go
and whether the [ __ ] comb-over or the
clam gets in the house it's going to go
in the direction that the money wants it
to go into and if it doesn't okay
they're going to Dallas right and
they're not going to be an attack 'la
they're going to [ __ ] roll out that
63 [ __ ] stretched Lincoln convertible
that's right they're going to get the
old right there Fred - they're [ __ ]
Jesus Christ the two of them you know
what I mean their heads you know what if
I was in Secret Service there would be a
head size that you could not be above
you know or else the president would
have to sign a waiver just like you know
both of them Hillary and [ __ ] and
Trump they have they have like like if
you could make sliders out of Ted
Kennedy's head that's what the [ __ ] they
have that is the most amazing thing
about Ted Kennedy he had the biggest
[ __ ] head out of all of them and he
nobody ever took him out you know you
would think that that [ __ ] guy out of
all of them they all had big squashes
right you know it's all good-looking men
- right you got to have a big head big
stupid head with the square jaw now look
in your eye like everything's going to
be okay the kind of thing that make
women go oh he could pay for all my
stuff right one of those heads well
what's his face
Ted Kennedy was ahead of his time no pun
intended right if you want to know how
fat people were going to get if you want
to know how big sodas were going to get
you want to know how [ __ ] ridiculous
you know McMansions and all this [ __ ]
and all the stuff that we were going to
by the age of consumerism right if you
were back in the 1950s trying to guess
you had to wager which way is it going
to go are we going to go back to living
on dirt floors and log cabins are we
going to have kegerators and [ __ ]
chocolate fountains in our houses all
you had to do is look at Ted Kennedy's
head and be like there it is that right
there that's an omen you know not
interesting thinking about Ted Kennedy's
head it was in his entire time he was
alive it was never backlit ever people
tried they just was never enough light
you know there's not even a picture of
him like blocking out the [ __ ] like
not even the Sun could reach around he
beside it just became night life when he
walked outside
hey I'm saying he had a big head you
know I got a big head I got a big head I
do literally and figuratively like a
giant head I got a [ __ ] ego and a
half because I got the whole week off
and what am I going to do I'm going to
rest up get ready for my European tour
like the red [ __ ] headed [ __ ] than I
am and I'm going to [ __ ] Tuesday
night I'm going to be at the Steve Allen
theatre on Hollywood Boulevard a
Boulevard of Dreams I'm going to be
there and just basically saying my [ __ ]
so you know I guess what I need to do is
just [ __ ] say it a few times right
just mutter it to myself walk around the
block talk to myself hands in my pocket
vigorously scratching the side of my
ballsack right having the cops come by
having them pull over asking me what I'm
doing do I live around here are you a
vagrant sorry do you guys see Rudy
Giuliani's speech about the policeman
that was one of the funniest [ __ ]
things I've ever seen in my life the way
he was trying to get that crowd going
you know they cut it out well take a
bonfire right I wanted him to keep going
you know
he just basically distraught described
police officers jobs but I wanted him to
keep going and I wanted him to betray
how wealthy he is and and the
influential friends that he has you know
they got the out
they say you're under arrest but you
have your lawyer made up in the driveway
and they say rodeo party so away I
[Music]
wanted I wanted them to go that far
because is the deal you know the way the
police are being painted right now is
[ __ ] ridiculous it's the same way you
know if one comic sucks then every
[ __ ] comic out there has a lampshade
on the [ __ ] head you know I mean
there's definitely some terrible people
that are police officers but that
doesn't mean that they're all bad okay
now Rudy Giuliani you can't [ __ ]
stand there where you exist in society
with your skin color and think that you
can accurately describe police officers
you know you need somebody a little more
mid-range well maybe it's good that he
said that okay now we got the high-end
right
black people [ __ ] said their end and
then you just need somebody in the
middle now you still can't do it still
can't do it because of racism you got to
try to balance the whole [ __ ] thing
out I don't know who knows a yeah you
think you know it be great with it with
the [ __ ] cell phone cameras and then
the cops film themselves what would be
great is if somebody [ __ ] up as a cop
if they actually got fired if they
actually [ __ ] were punished it went
to jail they actually murdered somebody
not like you know one or two or three
people if they'd actually just started
doing that I don't know I don't know I
don't know if there's any [ __ ]
solution to it you know what I mean it's
a hell of a [ __ ] job to have when you
got to walk up to a [ __ ] car not no
one if you got to get shot or not that
would make me a little edgy you know to
me I think a lot of [ __ ] can sit in
their [ __ ] living room perf when
they're perfectly safe being like
this is what I would have done right
like when you watch your [ __ ]
quarterback throw an interception and
then you say I would have dumped it off
to the tight end oh is that what you
would have done on your [ __ ] couch um
I think it's an impossible job and I
also think that's an element to that job
that [ __ ] sadistic psychopaths are
attracted to bouncers and all those
things there's a lot of people that just
want to beat the [ __ ] out of people that
go for that job then there's other ones
that go there they have their heart in
the right [ __ ] place you know but
they don't really make the noose you
know what I mean it's kind of like
comics like every night we tell jokes
nobody gets offended and then one can't
get [ __ ] offended elves is that what
it's like bill is somebody getting on
our something unarmed getting murdered
is like somebody getting in trouble for
a Caitlyn Jenner joke gee bill thanks
for [ __ ] explaining that one
now [ __ ] you it's my podcast okay I
choose not to read I choose not to be
informed that's my choice okay
I'm like one of those feminists you know
and they [ __ ] start yelling about
they don't tell me what they do with my
body right don't tell me what to do with
my podcast all right no more podcast
shaming oh [ __ ] I had the [ __ ]
greatest set I've had in [ __ ] months
Saturday night at the Comedy Store in
the main room there was this chunk of
material I've been trying to work out I
finally said it and work the right way
and then I came home I was so confident
of it I played it for my wife and even
she laughed and that's the deal when you
try something new this is this is this
is the litmus test and I mean what the
[ __ ] that means I don't know if I'm
saying it right
litmus latinus modal right my [ __ ]
test is I then play it for the lovely
meal and if she [ __ ] laughs you can
make your [ __ ] wife's get behind the
new [ __ ] that you're doing then you know
you're onto something you know because
in general what they do when they first
meet you they're like oh my god you're
amazing oh they just [ __ ] pumped you
up right so you start going like wow
cool man right and then once they get
you once you're [ __ ] in the
relationship once you give them the ring
and you get married then they [ __ ]
just grab the rain and shine you can bet
well in a world right they start yanking
the [ __ ] back not because they're jerks
it's just out of fear he's going to do
something new he's going to find
somebody new that's what they do
unlike guys everybody knows that men are
totally secure with who they are
I'm just doing this right now for any
guy who's listening to this podcast next
to a woman just to listen to her going
oh my god let me tell you something lady
alright and don't look at him right now
because he's not saying this I'm talking
to you sweetheart in the background
shaking your [ __ ] head at your man
who's going to die before you let him
have his laughs okay what you feel right
[ __ ] now is what a man feels when he
comes home and you're walking you're
watching those Botox squawkin [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay doing the recap of their
[ __ ] season with that Andy Cohen or
whatever his name is that [ __ ] genius
he's like he's like the Gabe Byron Allen
you know where they just found a show
where there was no show everybody was
like there's no show here and the genius
for that guy to be like yes there is
it's not enough that you got a bunch of
screaming [ __ ] yelling at each other
that someone's going to sit down and
watch it every [ __ ] night the fact
that he then does the recap and just
sits there you don't have to write
anything new they do it for you he just
sits there and effortlessly hosts the
show he's a master he just sits there
yeses this [ __ ] setlist like a comic
but all it is is to get these women
yelling at each other and he just he
just just watch the brilliance of that
man he just [ __ ] sits there and
if it's [ __ ] Simran he turns up the
heat you know you know in Episode four
Cathy she said she had some choice words
in the moment all yes person oh my god
when she called me a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then she goes and he just [ __ ] lays
back like Ali right and when he was
fighting George Foreman and he just lets
these women start [ __ ] punching each
other out and they run off set and he
sits there and this is the brilliance of
this man is he sits there and he
actually has a look on his face like he
truly gives a [ __ ] like he actually
gives a [ __ ] about these people he's
just sitting there going that's great TV
there we go that just sold some
toothpaste and he's just [ __ ] raking
it in look at the guy he looks like a
million bucks a lot of people don't know
this about that man he's 83 [ __ ]
years old you know everybody talking
about Dick Clark how great he looked
right to the [ __ ] end
yeah well close to being dead I should
have said that but [ __ ] you know
whatever we all go out like that right
but he's [ __ ] 83 a lot of people
don't know that you think the guy was
like you know like whatever what 37 I
have no [ __ ] idea there's got to be
people hosting real [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
different Coco why the [ __ ] didn't I
just do that what he is is he's doing a
sophisticated Jerry Springer
you know everybody's sitting down
there's no punches thrown they scream
and yell they cross their legs this is
one thing I'll say about the Real
Housewives their [ __ ] legs are
incredible it's [ __ ] amazing bill
legs like [ __ ] 22 year olds their
[ __ ] faces whoo you know Jesus Christ
and I got a lot of [ __ ] nerve saying
this considering the way I look
considering the way I traveled the world
looking like an albino balding Hellboy -
still working out right I look like this
thing if it was skinny and didn't have
that skin disease you know what I mean
but yet could not go out in the Sun
that's what I am I'm a middleweight
thing - whatever what's it made out of
real come on come on Comic Cons you know
what he's made
you know how he turned into that was it
another accident in a lab huh did he
come here from another planet and then
get bit by a spider and then got blinded
by some [ __ ] now he's a fast ant living
in somebody's [ __ ] head you know
driving a jet ski down to middle-earth
Jesus Christ yes when you think just
when you [ __ ] think that the Real
Housewife is the dumbest [ __ ] thing
you're ever going to watch they come out
with another stupid [ __ ] superhero
movie jesus [ __ ] christ
can somebody get me just collectively
get these nerds some hookers you know
why don't think the way wonder where the
kids go on now it takes what is that
what is that [ __ ] you know one of
those apps whatever the [ __ ] is it's
not is it tinder one of them is like the
Holy One and then the other ones like
you know like to Scully to food and
lingling to him boom free children you
know the douche app that you got the
other ones just like you know hey you
know I got some booze you know I got a
ding-a-ling I want to stick it in your
[ __ ] yep [ __ ] key all there
whatever it is that's [ __ ] amazing
god bless this generation you know I
mean that's [ __ ] great they have that
you know it's weird every year like life
becomes easier you have to think less
but it gets more expensive it's [ __ ]
nuts you know what I mean I can tell you
right now if there was [ __ ] free porn
and there was these dating sites you how
much easier your [ __ ] life would have
been when you were a kid just not having
a [ __ ] Oh God Jesus I remember having
to go out to those stupid [ __ ] you
just going out to these [ __ ] clubs
you know I was going out there in the
[ __ ] late 80s walking into a
nightclub
pop pop down pop it up without bow don't
open don't flap that girl is poison
ah anybody with their [ __ ] puffy ass
it's walking around we're a driving
gloves inside [ __ ] music louder [ __ ]
you know now you can sit there and your
[ __ ] underwear just scrolling through
people like you're a [ __ ] rock star
one
you know like whenever you hear that
[ __ ] like how the roadies would go out
and pick the [ __ ] women that the band
was going to [ __ ] maybe like yeah you
but your friends got to stay and then
the [ __ ] friend would leave me she's
like marthy and she just [ __ ] walks
away just for one night would to [ __ ]
the guy some guy from deep purple right
and then years later the two of them
meet you know at a high school reunion
and then the [ __ ] one that left the
other one left marcy behind is all
[ __ ] nervous that Marcy's going to
let her now-husband know that she [ __ ]
you know the maracas player the maracas
player from deep purple he wasn't even a
full member they just had him on for
that one [ __ ] song because Santana's
scared the [ __ ] out of them they thought
that was the direction of music was
going to go then once they realized that
mainstream music was only going to
accept one Santana right and there
wasn't going to be another [ __ ] type
of Santa and tell those guys bah bah and
then there was Ricky Martin Adama bah
bah bah bah right and years [ __ ]
later at there at the fair at the
[ __ ] high-speed the high school
reunion and she's just [ __ ] with their
eyes she's trying to be like oh so good
to see you
she's [ __ ] like bringing her in like
you know trying to [ __ ] sort of
muffler and choke her out like I'll
[ __ ] take [ __ ] tonight and then I
slap them around screaming hot and deep
purple right and then Marcy she's just
not she's a woman she's just not going
to come out and say it was the fun there
then then it's over you know it's like a
cat playing with the mouse she's just
getting a linger
she's going to start talking to the
husband yeah act at all interests not
looking at [ __ ] you know Marcy right
and that she's going to kind of glance
over at her and that she's just going to
just slowly let it out yeah me and your
wife yeah we were crazy back then
remember all those concert we went to
and she's just going to watch there I
forget who's Marcy at this point the
[ __ ] chick who got let we'll just say
Marcy's the married one alright he's
just going to see her face [ __ ] fall
it's his [ __ ] chick just twist the
[ __ ] nice is she going to tell is she
not going to tell and then she'll back
off and change the subject
and then she'll gradually come back
around to it and this [ __ ] guy's just
standing there doesn't know a [ __ ]
thing I'm sorry I was just you know I
was just doing a table read for a
[ __ ] screenplay I'm writing called
Marcy's a [ __ ]
you know and I've been shopping around
Hollywood forever and I tell you is
great if the script is for whatever
[ __ ] reason they just cannot get past
the title you know it's just this
politically correct age that we live in
all right let's get to some of the reads
here for this week now for Christ's sake
bill did you even [ __ ] did you even
[ __ ] now you didn't there we go
alright here we go for reads Indo Chino
Indochina the [ __ ] says talk about how
good it feels to have a suit that is one
of kind is uniquely yours talk about how
when you look good you feel confident
let me talk about that why don't you
[ __ ] write some [ __ ] for me to talk
about what is this an interview talk
about wearing suits
alright Indochina window Chino all right
Indo Chino is reinventing all I remember
these guys all these guys actually I
don't know why I'm [ __ ] on him these
guys are [ __ ] great hey heating it up
yeah I'll talk about this hey you member
matter when you had to go to that
[ __ ] thing and you had to wear a
[ __ ] suit and you put it on and you
look like you're lost thirty pounds
because it was your older brothers you
know would it be nice to have a suit
that just completely fit you was totally
custom made and measured
measured out your arms and your legs and
your crotch right seeing how far down
your balls hang would that be great
except it didn't cost a zillion bucks
well you couldn't do that but now
there's endo Chino Indochina they are
reinventing men's fashion and I'm made
to measure suit is the best suit you'll
ever own so suit up get a one-of-a-kind
made-to-measure suit custom customized
as details you want pick your lining
lapels personal monogrammed there you go
is it good one every chick even these
seven it's like when a guy is as
initials on the [ __ ] cuffs right and
more the [ __ ] happened to the AC 14
unique measurements go into making a
suit that fits you perfectly you can't
go wrong with the well-crafted 100%
merino wool suit also check out the [ __ ]
like a wolf suit in August also check
out their made to mesh measure dress
shirts and men's accessories money-back
guarantee T money-back guarantee today
my listeners get any premium suit just
for 399 that's up to 50% off at
Indochina calm when entering BER and
check out plus shipping is free there's
no reason not to try your first
custom-made suit with a deal that's good
in a classic suit from their premium
collection will look good feel good in
less that's Indochina com promo code bar
any premium suit for just 399 free
shipping that's Indo Chino or China
look your look your way okay that was a
rough one all right
o dollars shakedown dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing races right to your
door for a third of the price of what
the greedy raisin corporation shat you
know why then we have a [ __ ] you that
means you could join Dollar Shave Club
you can afford to shave with a fresh
blade anytime you want which feels
fantastic you get a first-class shave
when you use the executive blade oh yeah
and that's without even hurt your wallet
and when you use the executive razor
with dr. cabbies easy shame vada the
blade just glides gently for the
smoothest shave
shave butter do people can do cocaine
off your cheek that's how [ __ ] smooth
it's going to be dice it right up oh god
that would hurt shea butter isn't your
average shave cream it's a unique
conditioning formula with high quality
natural ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth now is a
great time to join Dollar Shave Club new
members who buy a tub a tube sorry shave
butter get a month of the executive
razor for free take advantage of this
special offer today it's available by
going to dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / alright what do
you got left - more - more hang in there
score big high you're paying too much
for tickets between all the markups and
last-minute convenience changes even
print-at-home feet you're [ __ ]
kidding me here you end up paying
courtside prices for nosebleed seats
score big is here to change all of that
did you know that 40% of all live event
tickets go on so and did you know
there's a place to get these take seats
and a you say it's called score big
score bed works directly with your
favorite teams and artists to get their
unsold seats at unpublished prices only
with score big can you name a ticket
price I want and begin to eat the page
below box office up to 60% off here's
what you got to do you don't have to do
it but this is what you should do one
uno go to score become or download the
news I just realize when French people
[ __ ] today does the woman think she that
guy's counting or she just you know
[ __ ] you know uh sorry uh go to score
big calm or download the new score big
app for your iPhone and find the event
and seats you want to make an offer with
score bigs name a ticket price feature
get an instant answer pump 60% off your
tickets never any fees and shipping is
always free you can count on an
unbeatable prices and great seats and
when you're in great seats actually
enjoy the game or the show all the
yeah because you got more chance at
being next to some gold-digging [ __ ]
might give you a [ __ ] handy if you
got your initials on your sleeves if
next time you go see any game a show go
to score big first and see how much you
can save for the easiest Jesus Christ we
get it for the easiest way to save on
tickets download the new score big app
for your iPhone enter the promo code
bird to checkout and you'll save an
extra twenty bucks off your first
tickets per purchase no iPhone no
problem go steal one punch an old lady
in the head though get to $20 off online
get $20 off online
- which score big combat score big
compro moco burr score big calm promo
code birth lastly but not leastly stance
calm everybody
you know tips to the post office have
probably become second nature to you
they seem easy because you've been doing
your mailing and shipping that way for
so long and you live in a first world
country so you don't have to walk nine
miles with a basket on your head to go
get some water while you fight off a
Cobra
but think about all the hassle man
dropping what you're doing driving there
finding parking and waiting there's a
much better way Oh
Stan's calm everybody Stan's calm is the
easiest convenient way to get postage
right from your desk by imprint official
US postage using your own company and
with Stan's calm there's no guesswork
you don't have to thank you [ __ ] dope
they make it easy to get exact postage
for any letter package class of mail the
instant you need it no expensive postage
meters to lease no more trips to the
post office you have to try you don't
have to but you should I use Stan's calm
anytime I'm paying to ship out my
posters and I'm going to warm myself up
meet the public every 11th person is
going to have a [ __ ] sweaty palm maybe
there'll be a tall guy you can put his
arm around me and I can feel the heat of
his sweaty armpit making my right
shoulder blade damp through my shirt
sign up for Stan's calm and use my last
name BER for this special offer for week
trial plus $110 bonus offer that in
clause the post ads and a digital scale
no wait go to Stan's car before you do
anything
click on the microphone top of the
homepage and type in fur that stance
calm and to birth
alright now that we got that out of the
way it's time to go back to the pool
pool did anybody watch the Hungary grand
prix yesterday did you what did you
Lewis Hamilton wins again Nico Rosberg
came in second and now Lewis Hamilton
that's the fifth time he won that race I
learned that he passed out Craig
shoemaker stand-up comedian and
legendary [ __ ] f1 drivers know
Michael Schumacher every for every other
Grand Prix driver sounds like the
guitarist and scorpions can't miss
scorpions I should say you always [ __ ]
up about that trend I don't know [ __ ]
about this sport it just seemed whoever
was in first like like the race was to
the first turn and then it was just
[ __ ] over you couldn't get past
anybody you know who is that [ __ ]
lunatic zigzagging behind the red bull
huh going back and forth he cut off the
front of his [ __ ] car
was it Sebastian Vettel was it max first
stopping
Bennett that bedded Kimi räikkönen was
the driver of the day I think wasn't
like a [ __ ] 90th place and he moved
up to like seventh to some [ __ ] I am its
warmest race for fourth was really
entertaining but I didn't like how you
know there was no way for [ __ ] Nico
to even try to pass Lewis once he got
out in front that [ __ ] track it was
just you know kind of stunk like what
was Hamilton was just driving right the
whole [ __ ] time and you know they
were just showing like the race for
fourth and fifth and third and fourth
and then like they were on the final lap
and it was so [ __ ] boring out front
they were still back you know watching
that guy zigzag ok Formula one fans I
don't understand whether I like the
[ __ ] rules well bill why don't you
look them up well
it's easier to ask you guys it's also
funny if I talk about him and I don't
know what I'm talking about I don't get
out when the guy who cut off the front
of his car right one of the [ __ ] fins
I did find it funny that they were like
yeah people do that all the time and it
doesn't affect the performance of the
car doesn't seem to anyways well they
were saying you were only allowed to
make one move like he went to the right
and then he came back to the left and
then back to the right and it was
considered more than one move and I was
just like what the [ __ ] he can't do that
I thought I left this behind with the
NFL season yeah that this is like you
know he's got to make a football move
that [ __ ] guy when he tried to go
around the other dude didn't do anything
that I don't do when I'm on the highway
when I'm behind some [ __ ] douche
driving too [ __ ] slow on the left
lane right oh you know what in I'm in
the UM in the second to left lane right
now some guy driving medium speed and
then somebody doing that just making a
wall and I'm like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and
then you go around to the right coming
her ass now when I watched the race it
was Lewis Hamilton then Rosberg and I
remember it was a red bull than a
Ferrari then a red bull then a Ferrari
and then today it's saying red bull
Ferrari Ferrari red bull so did somebody
get penalized
it's [ __ ] unreal I don't get it like
yeah there's always like after the
[ __ ] wrong you thought you won the
race but uh somebody said something in
ta don't shift into seventh gear and
they're like all you can't do that don't
tell him what he shouldn't do you know
he's only driving a car at two hundred
[ __ ] miles an hour
one guy spun out that was it there
wasn't really any uh crashes or anything
like that but he was funny I'm actually
totally until my wife can't stand it she
said when I have it on it sounds like a
bunch of bees flying around but it still
[ __ ] cruller shipped over that I
don't know that was probably of all the
races I watch that's been my least
favorite just because there was always
like the start of the race was the most
exciting and there was just a bunch of
people in the back trying to go around
people and they couldn't do it except
for Kimi räikkönen the flying Finn
see the fly-infinity lucking idea
anyways but this is really getting me
through the [ __ ] dog days of baseball
I [ __ ] love baseball but I just you
know I can't get into it in July in
August I like it in April you know in
the May you start seeing what's going to
happen and then I just [ __ ] veg out
June July August the same way the
players do right did you stand up there
like dude what the [ __ ] how many [ __ ]
games do you have to play in the regular
season before we know who deserves to
win the division 162 5 minutes isn't
that insane that has to be if you're
going to own a professional team that's
got to be the sport to do it a hundred
and sixty two home games your team's
selling out the ballpark Jesus Christ
those things have to be I got look this
up right now look at this I'm actually
gonna do research professional so you
know franchises I shall put sports in
there right now someone going to be
[ __ ] talking being bob mcdonnell's
worth the most okay well is everything
okay the Dallas Cowboys for whatever
reason are worth four billion dollars
Real Madrid John guessing is some sort
of football club in Spain is worth three
point seven billion dollars and then
there's another one in Barcelona that
also Spain three point six billion the
New York Yankees there you go well that
makes sense that like world football as
we call it soccer would be worth that
much money because that that really is
when you win a World Championship you're
winning the World Cup you're playing
against the [ __ ] world right it's
like an Olympic medal except you get
paid then the New York Yankees three
point four billion then man united three
point three billion
oh and then the New England Patriots
everybody's favorite [ __ ] team they
ate on 3.2 billion then the New York
Knicks what three billion Jesus Christ
New York I'll tell you that's a
fixer-upper right that New York Knicks
are a [ __ ] teardown
oh this is weird man
then the Washington Redskins 2.9 billion
hey shut up I hate when this happened
now you got to figure out where the [ __ ]
the voice is coming from
shut up while there it is all right all
right the Redskins are worth 2.9 billion
then the Giants are 2.8 building
building billion then the Lakers a two
point set the Lakers are worth less than
the Knicks if anything says that this
state is going to fall into the ocean
one day it's that the fact that the
[ __ ] mix are with more [ __ ] money
than the [ __ ] Lakers Jesus Christ
what are the Celtics worth oh my god rap
reports going to [ __ ] love that well
you know something that actually makes
sense because you know when you move to
Manhattan you're [ __ ] can you [ __ ]
let me get to the site I hate when
[ __ ] sites do this they just got to
suck the [ __ ] information out of you
Forbes let me give you my [ __ ] email
what so Time magazine can start [ __ ]
spamming me I don't think so why Hillary
Clinton should be thankful election is
not today otherwise her pantsuits all in
the [ __ ] dry cleaners all right let's
uh let's just wait where am i how much
time have I done 41 minutes you know
some days it feels like work other days
it doesn't you know I've become obsessed
with as of last night
is you know I've been doing this grip
strength thing and I've been [ __ ]
doing great man I can go
but pegboard now at 48 years of age I
can go up a climbing rope leaving my
skinny [ __ ] alabaster [ __ ] albino
legs just dangling like a [ __ ] I
don't know a couple of appendices right
Jesus I never had to make that plural
appendix appendices tits today's yeah
because you know what I got those those
atomic [ __ ] holes there's a lot of
[ __ ] better send me some free [ __ ]
I'm sick I hate on those guys up but
they're the [ __ ] they are the [ __ ] so
now I want to be able to do one of those
to call the front lever or front lever
and I watch this guy's a YouTube video
I'll repost it the six easy steps
hey lovely Nia to being able to do a
front Liva did you hear about Paula
Abdul she's she's a singer and she was a
Laker girl okay thank you come on to the
Mike Mike Mike baby you do dude why did
you do that about Paula Abdul um cuz I
love fall absolutely I know I like Megan
love I had to pick someone you know if I
can go did you hear about Paula Abdul
like this mom money lot is funny it is
funny and you're gonna sit there and act
like you're not going to do it to me
that's true what would you pick hmm one
of your rock icons probably you know
kind of helps you pick a name well I
can't tell you because it's not going to
be a surprise when I do it all right
no it isn't because you already told me
you're going to do it see what I did
there
oh yeah I guess I could flip it I don't
know it's the morning still drinking
your juice I brought it for you oh thank
you
well I got to do a podcast you don't
mind no I people give me [ __ ] cuz I try
not to drink on the mic but I have to
hold the microphone take all right then
talk to them will I drink it
okay so my snapchat last night if you
guys follow me on snapchat
I made my fresh-squeezed hahahaha
watermelon juice I'm giving it to Villa
who loves the Wow taking it down like a
champ you give them with me anything in
this glass I stuck it down just like my
my juice I drink at night daddy's
medicine daddy's medicine alright I got
to get back to the podcast Mia okay
alrighty alright okay what's doc mount
um I don't really know this has just
been one of these stream of conscious
days that's the whole podcast I talked
about some lady with a basket on her
head trying to get water while she
fought off a Cobra I do remember that
okay I also talked about how big the
heads are of the people running for
president and I would be concerned if I
was the head of security mm-hmm okay
what else that's all I can remember
oh riveting okay all right I'll see you
hey Nene do you hear about Lady gaga
she had a meat dress all right let's get
to some of the questions here oh yeah
yes I became obsessed with the that
front lever and this guy has a six-step
thing on how to do it because I always
want to be able to do the human [ __ ]
flag you know that's just a great thing
to be able to do if you're not a gymnast
because people just expect you to be
able to do it but if you just like a dad
you got a couple of kids you know you're
[ __ ] into roofing now that's a
physical job whatever you [ __ ] build
I don't know it just be something just
funny to do that you could actually
[ __ ] do that just weird people up you
know that reminds me I wanted to do a
bit on these [ __ ] CrossFit people but
I just feel like it's just too happy and
every comics going to have a bid on it
so what what's why do these CrossFit
people why do they have to like work out
in the gym and outside why is it just so
[ __ ] look at me we're working out I
work out too I work out my garage with
the [ __ ] door closed
it's the most narcissistic sheen you
ever seen then just like did [ __ ]
running down the street with like a
goddamn [ __ ] tire behind them right
somebody show me a picture of a guy
doing that I am retweeted it right
running down the street dragging a tire
when you just run up a hill you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know whose attire Ed's more
difficulty when they run up the hill
more times increase your reps you stupid
[ __ ] what are you training for the stand
like I was [ __ ] somewhere in Santa
Monica these [ __ ] jerk-offs there's
like 10 of them outside and they got you
know and they got the double [ __ ]
ropes that are a thing that they do
that's the only reason you really need
to do that is if you're fighting in the
UFC they're the only people who seem to
need to have to do that then everybody
else wants to be in UFC shape without
having to actually have the balls to get
in the Octagon alright so [ __ ] dumb
and or even when they're inside there's
like down the street there's one from me
it's like this giant garage door and
they just have it open like look at us
we're CrossFitting
I talked to me about it she was saying
like yeah it was like all the rage to be
on one of those social media thing and
like oh I did you know dick filming
yourself working out hashtag CrossFit
it's just I don't when I was when I was
a kid if you wanted people to look at
you you got into show business okay you
became a male stripper you told jokes
you joined a band you know now these
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're making a bundt
cake and they got like [ __ ] 80,000
[ __ ] hits and everybody's walking
around with the same arrogance that I
have it's not fair people I earned I
earned my arrogance I'm [ __ ] with you
you want to work outside you want to run
down the street with a [ __ ] tire
behind you you know what I mean I don't
quite understand when to apply the white
privilege thing because I am white and
who's kidding who I am one of the
whitest of all time you know what I mean
I would say Hitler would not be
disappointed if I walked into his office
but I think the red hair I think I might
be out once Chuck white skinned Chuck
wants the blue eyes yeah or this one's
defective all right if you want to help
donate to this podcast without having to
do [ __ ] anything except by something
on amazon.com just go to my website
billboard.com okay and there's an amazon
app there you click on that thing it
takes you right to Amazon doesn't cost
you any extra money I just get credit
for driving traffic to their site and
then they kick me a little doremi you
didn't have to do nothing nobody knows
anything and you know whatever I go out
I buy myself a ham sandwich you can do
it if you want to get dope that's fine
if you're listening to this podcast
you're like I hate this thing gee I wish
there was a podcast network that had a
bunch of other podcasts to choose from I
would say to go to all things comedy
calm the podcast network started by
myself and al Madrigal and a bunch of
other people
we got Irish your fear over there I
should really go on the website right
now and give you and give you a bunch of
[ __ ] names right Oh things comedy
right of all the people I use the
podcast with all right what do we have
here oh we got Dean Dell Rhea's let
there be talk Chris sane and Anna David
I have no control over my vagina how do
you not [ __ ] listen to that we got
Steve Simone uh we got Doug Stanhope my
[ __ ] goddamn eyes are going I can't
even read half of these [ __ ] things
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank we got a with
Aaron Foley sports without balls I mean
we got whatever the [ __ ] you want we got
it over there all things comedy calm
alright let's read some [ __ ] here for
this week
shall we 50 minutes in professor dickwad
hey Bill you hemoglobin Laden
erythrocyte I had to look all of that up
that's basically saying I have a lot of
red in me little red blood cell Vegas
let's make this as short and sweet as
possible all right
why are you [ __ ] a lecture me you
[ __ ] I go to a nice College I also
manage a movie theater in my town to you
why would you say also an - I manage a
movie theater in my town also or two -
and also mean the same thing right but I
also manage a movie theater in my town -
comma - all right
at school I've got a film you've said
you can make it short and sweet at
school I've got a I got a film studies
class with one of those pretentious
[ __ ] professors that wears young kid
clothes to come off cooler than he
really is yeah you know what that means
he's going to [ __ ] a student I love
movies I've seen plenty of them that's
the reason why I'm taking this class
well that's great gravitate to what you
want what you want every time before we
watch your movie in this class the
professor asks us to raise our hands if
we've seen it before I raise my hand
almost every time then I look around to
see if anyone else is raising their hand
they rarely are sure I'm a nerd I've
seen the [ __ ] movies maybe if you
didn't play the most standard choices
like Casablanca and [ __ ] I wouldn't
raise my hand every time look at that
you like movies you're doing your
homework you're taking a class on it
you're grabbing what you want very nice
all right so anyway I was just recently
hired I was just recently hired on an
employee don't you kill me I just
recently hired on as an employee you
left out the ass at my theater who also
happens to be a student of my film
studies pursue oh you went by an
employee so anyway I just recently I was
just recently hired by an employee at my
theater who also happens to be a student
of my film studies professor but in a
different class at a different school I
think I conveyed what you were trying to
say that
as a joke one day I asked the kid so
does mr. so-and-so ever talk [ __ ] about
our class the kid looks me square in the
eye and says yeah actually he does dr.
so-and-so says there's this one kid in
your your your all's class
you mean y'all's class who always raises
his hand when he asks if he's seen the
movie but really he probably hasn't and
then he looks around the room to make
sure everyone is looking at him to know
he's seen the movie before
that's hilarious this guy's getting
insecure you're making your teacher
insecure so he's got involved Jesus
that's probably why he's wearing the
young people's clothes he's talking [ __ ]
about the other class to make himself
seem cool ah
this guy's a [ __ ] this guy's a [ __ ]
I don't like this teacher he goes so
there we go this guy talks [ __ ] about me
to his other classes when all I'm doing
is generally raising my hand after being
asked if I've seen the movie or not in
any other case I'd probably just
confront him about this but I don't to
risk failing the class or something
petty like that am i overthinking this
what should I do here I walk right up to
the guy I just boy who gives a [ __ ] this
[ __ ] insecure [ __ ] he'll probably
give you a better grade because with his
need to be like just walk right up to
him bed yeah listen man there seems to
be some confusion on your part that you
seem to be trying to work out with the
other class as to why I raise my hand
every time I happen to love movies I
work at a movie theater okay and I've
seen all these movies and I look around
just to see if anybody else has seen the
movies because I love movies and I want
to talk to people about movies if you
don't want me to keep you know raising
my hand
stop doing this paint-by-numbers basic
horseshit movies that you keep picking
what are you gonna have next week days
of saga huh you giving me [ __ ] you're
going to come any address like you keep
going to a [ __ ] yeah I don't know
what are those young kids listen to I
you just go see the weekend is that the
right thing who's the other guy who's
the rapper who won all the [ __ ]
Grammys Kendrick Lamar
I know who they are I don't I know a few
of their songs I know the weekend CD
starts off going wait wait you can
actually play the beginning of the
weekend I think rednecks do it as much
as they probably don't like your skin
color they probably play that when
they're out duck huntin to try to get
the young dunk
you know we're into all this [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] with you I am a fan of the
weekend a little a little and well it
was hardly that last yokai little fella
all right a billy calorie count thoughts
on Melissa McAfee getting flack for
losing weight all right my first thought
uh Melissa McCarthy I did a movie with
her and number eight years ago was
called the heat
directed by Paul Feig starring Melissa
McCarthy Sandra Bullock and that's where
I first met uh Michael Rapaport you know
dropping names all over the place and
she is truly one of the most naturally
funny [ __ ] hilarious human beings I
have ever met and she's an absolute
sweetheart so anyways I didn't realize
people given why would you give somebody
flak for losing weight aren't you
supposed to say hey great job good for
you you know anyway said people are
saying she's doing it because of
Hollywood pressures that's so [ __ ]
dumb alright and if people are just add
anything that's not what it is it's it's
it's it's the same County mentality when
you're finally deciding that you know
wearing your football jacket and
continuing to drink in the local bar you
want more out of life and then all of us
always thank you smart now like all of
them they don't want to see her get her
[ __ ] together you know misery loves
[ __ ] company you know they would stay
here and be out of shape good for
[ __ ] [ __ ] what kind of an [ __ ]
when somebody makes a positive move in
their life tries to make it negative
well me I'm a comedian I do that all the
time but besides people like me anyways
these people who always say you should
be comfortable in your own
no matter what you look like completely
ignore basic information like clogged
arteries and such absolutely maybe
Melissa McCarthy doesn't want to die of
a heart attack because she wants to meet
her grandchildren one day I lost 30
pounds since listening to you fetch team
everyone I honestly didn't know I was
getting fat I was never fat ever but
then three years in an office job in
college I'm 24 I put on the gross 30 I
recently lost yeah dude at 24 man you
were headed towards being you were going
to die you were 30 pounds overweight at
24 that is not a good thing so
congratulations
anyways he said I feel a thousand times
better I never looked fat because I'm a
tall guy and I carry it well so I never
heard anything from anyone I did it on
my own for myself these fat defenders
are ignorantly judging and assuming
thoughts on this also when the [ __ ] do
we get to see your gym video I want to
see your pasty legs dangling from a
pull-up bar
like meat hanging in a locker you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
no this is the thing about this business
the only pressure that it is as far as
I'm concerned the only pressure in this
business is what you excu as an
individual choose to accept all right
and everybody does it to a certain point
when you first get into entertainment
because you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're doing you come into this business
with your hat in hand you're like I'll
sweep the floors I'll do whatever you
want just give me stage time I'll I'll
drive to another state to do five
minutes for no money for five dollars
gas money we all do that [ __ ] but at
some point you then have to put a value
on what the [ __ ] it is you're doing
right and then you start getting paid
then what happens is you're like going
[ __ ] you know is you know you get in
this business it takes a while to get
going and everybody starts creeping in
2:30 so you start freaking out going Oh
what is what is the industry casting
what are they looking at what is the
blah blah blah and all that type of [ __ ]
ok now a lot of people do not ever get
past that because they don't put a value
on their talent and I'm not even talking
monetarily this is just my own belief
system you have to believe that you have
something to say
that you know you can't be married to
the results you just got to do that Zen
thing like I'm talking about this [ __ ]
I'm doing this and like take me all
right I came into the business all right
a [ __ ] redheaded [ __ ] male you know
so from day one
there's not going to be a lot of roles
for me there's not a lot of redheaded
male leads and [ __ ] you know I'm the
friend right
that's the deal it's our works the
redheaded male is not the [ __ ] cool
guy so to make matters worse I started
losing my [ __ ] hair and I was like ah
[ __ ] now what do I go out and get plugs
and all that [ __ ] and just one day right
up you know Neil just buzz your [ __ ]
head down and I was just like I just
came to this epiphany of just like yeah
bill why you walking around like you
losing your [ __ ] hair is a big deal
does that mean you're not funny anymore
does that mean you know what were you
going to be the next Brad Pitt if you
kept your [ __ ] hair right and then I
just said yeah [ __ ] it so then I did it
and this and I ever since I had the
philosophy of basically this is what I
look like and this is what I do if you
want to book me thank you if you don't I
understand the second I went into that
mindset I never [ __ ] stressed again
so I really think that all that whole
you know the pressures of [ __ ] in
Hollywood is I understand that when
you're young but as you're getting older
you have to [ __ ] it really has
nothing to do with Hollywood I also I
think it has more to do with you know
why you got into this business you know
the self-loathing you know and not
liking yourself I think and I have to
tell you this past weekend I watched Ali
Wong special and it was so [ __ ] great
and I was sitting there with my wife and
I was saying like what I loved she went
out there and it just was she was [ __ ]
original all of her stuff was just you
just [ __ ] it was just a great set it was
worthy like this
was a stand-up special and you know she
went out there you know and everybody's
making a big [ __ ] deal that it like
because she was pregnant that she did
element got all these [ __ ] questions
and I understand why they did that
because no one's ever done that but
there should be more questions about how
great the material was but I was saying
to my wife when I was watching this I go
you see this she had a special to do and
she didn't give a [ __ ] that she was
pregnant and she just walked out and
then she owned it and now what she's
done is she's established herself that
now she can just basically do whatever
the [ __ ] she wants she wants to have
another kid she can literally go on tour
while pregnant because she's established
that this is Who I am is what I'm doing
I'm married I'm starting to [ __ ]
family and I'm writing killer jokes this
is what I'm doing now
all these [ __ ] feminists who sit
there going and again Hollywood not let
you be pregnant I would argue you're
giving them way too much [ __ ] power
way too much power just go out if every
[ __ ] woman out here just started
getting pregnant because they wanted to
and continue to go on auditions the
whole [ __ ] business would adjust
you make it adjust to you rather than
the other [ __ ] way around and if you
haven't seen her special you know you
know a lot of the hype on it is the fact
that she did it seven months pregnant
but I'm telling you just as someone who
still of you know as long as I've been
doing is a huge fan of stand-up comedy
you know it's the jokes of a [ __ ]
killer
the subject matter all of it it was just
like you know God knows his a zillion
[ __ ] specials out there but you know
every once in a while you know someone
comes out like with that that was that
was one of the best ones I've seen in a
while so I guess I would tie all of that
back into that it's like I would say
that she's losing weight yeah she's
married she's got kids and what the who
the [ __ ] doesn't want to lose weight I'm
trying to lose weight no one wants to
walk around being overweight it's not
fun your life is easier and people who
give a [ __ ] about that I would just say
you know
I feel bad for them because I know they
don't want to be out of shape too you
know I mean cities they being proud to
be out of shape that's like being proud
to be like a [ __ ] alcoholic you know
you know you got issues your [ __ ]
heart isn't [ __ ] excited that you're
overweight like that's right that's
right
every pound of fat is five miles of
capillaries
you know you get 20 pounds overweight
your heart's gotta [ __ ] go an extra
100 miles every [ __ ] beat you didn't
stupid it's not it's not a good thing to
be doing so congratulations to her
but you know I'm struggling right now to
lose [ __ ] well I'll tell you he it's
not easy
booze bag all right Christian girls
sexual boundaries hey Billy beau Berman
I listened to all your specials multiple
times and really love the advice
segments you do on your podcast I'm back
home for the summer from my first year
of college and I'm hooking up with this
six to ten Christian what Oh 6 out of 10
Christian girl the last couple of months
of school I barely even just retained
any of that because I was hoping
everything that I said came off as
positive and that last thing
anyway let me reread this I've listened
to all your Santa today back for the
summer
okay I'm hooking up with the skirt this
six out of ten Christian girl the last
couple months of school the encounters
basically consisted of me aggressively
finger plat Liv G easy easy things are
blasting her to quench her sexual
deviancy I love how you're just [ __ ]
innocent in all this and her giving my
oh oh okay okay oh this is a woman
rightness in her again forgiving my
carpet a midnight snack
what oh no it's the guy why you saying
your carpet give it my carpet a midnight
snack while jerking me off
you lost me in that one what is your
carpet you puked
what is this snack could you come on
yourself I don't even know what's going
on here
Ernie what she's a devout Christian so
she won't get involved with oral sex or
anything further now the thing is her
idea of boundaries are pretty amorphous
I know what that means now you [ __ ]
[ __ ] now I got a look you know I
actually keep doing this maybe I'll get
smart one day amorphous amorphous
without a clear defined shape or form
how do I never hear that my whole
[ __ ] life there's so many [ __ ]
words the English language didn't they
always say that but we use like nineteen
of four from our curse words all right
she's begged me to pleasure her with the
hilt of my screwdriver do to you from
another century what the [ __ ] is a hilt
is that the handle don't know why I even
had one at college and jerk me off under
her face when we took a late night
sleepover shower together yeah but
that's not really a facial when the
water is right there you know what it
mate it's like you know you're going to
run out here then you'll walk on some
hot rocks and you just [ __ ] do a
running leap and touch one for half a
second you keep going right she's also
into being it's like picking up dog [ __ ]
with the little [ __ ] plastic bag
around your hand you know you still
touching dog [ __ ] but you feel the
warmth of it but you know there's a
boundary there she's also into being
choked and tied up there jesus [ __ ]
christ
up during dry humping apparently that
stuff still Christian enough for her
I've had sex a few times before the ski
why are you judging this girl so harshly
alright this is this religion thing this
is where she's at just [ __ ] relax
seems like avin a hell of a time because
I had sex a few times before this girl
and know that even protected [ __ ] is
infinitely more plausible than
outsourced masturbation my question to
you is do you think she'll ever realize
how ridiculous it is to take a load on a
face but not accept cunnilingus will she
ever want premarital sex I know I should
go to a gym lose this girl get some
sleek and take advantage of the [ __ ]
Coliseum that is my universe can't
University campus but I'm lazy and want
to [ __ ] the low-hanging fruit what can I
do to convince her that college sex is
natural wholesome it would make her feel
incredible thanks so much and go [ __ ]
yourself I would say you should let this
girl go because you don't have any
feelings forward you're using those or
you're using her as a [ __ ] blow-up
doll you just say you know I know I
should go meet some other people but
this girl's an easy [ __ ] sex hookup I
don't know I mean meantime is she
getting feelings for you because if you
just sitting there hanging around
waiting to be able to [ __ ] her so that
you can then leave you already saying
she's a six out of 10 that's that
doesn't sound like you have feelings for
so I'd let her go I'd let it go and I'd
find some girl then just in just let
them know you're young so I'm not
judging you here what you got to do
early on and this is what nobody ever
tells young men it's just just out of
the gate tell women what the deal is all
right
because believe it or not they can have
fun they don't flip out when you just
say yeah there's no way I'm going to
marry you
you know if you say it right from the
beginning the second you meet right if
you're not feeling anything but you just
attracted to them just tell them that
and just [ __ ] let them you know work
that out and maybe they're in the same
place you are they just want to [ __ ]
they don't want to have a relationship
but if you get into that type of a
situation you got to make sure that you
got to have like you know you [ __ ]
then you don't call each other a talk or
do anything else you do not hang out and
there's got to be at least 10 days
between the [ __ ] hookups or somebody
starts feeling something and then it's a
[ __ ] mess or they get jealous because
you with somebody else or whatever you
know what I mean and this is what you
[ __ ] say from day one you tell them
that
all right you still will get a hookup
anything you ever wanted to [ __ ] do
you can do with me you're not going to
get judged you have to worry about
getting judged because it is what it is
right and then that's it we don't call
each other
this is what we just [ __ ] use each
other for this anytime you're feeling
horny if you're not in a [ __ ]
relationship I don't give a [ __ ] if you
date other people believe it or not if
you come out of the gate with that [ __ ]
you would be surprised how many women
are also looking for that it's a great
[ __ ] buddy is it's the greatest thing
ever greatest [ __ ] thing ever it's
like having [ __ ] I don't know free
tickets to Disneyland you get to write
down all the [ __ ] rides you know you
got VIP parking it's like ordering a
pizza it's tremendous and you know what
women also order pizza if you know what
I mean so have fun with that but let
this girl go man
all right first time flying at 30 years
of age hey there Billy the ginger bat
just want to say I've been a huge fan
for over 10 years and have loved every
special you had well thank you very much
I'm 30 I've never been on a plane and
Heights kind of freak me out to top it
off my flight is on 9/11 and makes two
stops in between here Connecticut in
Chicago I'm going there for my job and
I'd really hate to miss out on the
opportunity basically I'm just looking
for advice on how to not freak out and
look like a [ __ ] idiot on the plane
seeing us out you've had so much
experience flying I figured you'd be a
good person to talk to thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yes no big deal it's
completely safe and you know you're
going to be fine this is a deal you're
going to go up there right this is what
you do get on the plane and then just
say to the person next to you yet
believe it or not this is the first time
I've ever flown hopefully you're not
next to a douche if they seem open just
tell them that alright but believe me
you're not going to you've never just
stomped on the gas when you've been
driving a car and you just get back in
your seat it's just sort of like that
and then you [ __ ] up in the air and
it's the coolest thing ever it's [ __ ]
great and you're going to go from
[ __ ] Connecticut to Chicago in like
[ __ ] two seconds you know we got two
stops there okay
well that's cool be fun well then you'll
be a veteran by the end of it and yeah
welcome to the [ __ ] 21st century
you're going to be fine
what I would say is you know just make
sure you eat well
we go to the airport you know maybe
bring some food to go onto the plane
you know because the food on the plane
sucks it's [ __ ] overpriced and that
type of thing and uh you know that's the
only thing I would say other than that
you have nothing to worry about it's
going to be great get a [ __ ] window
seat to if you can't that's the best you
know first time you fly you get to look
down it's actually pretty incredible to
be doing that at thirty years of age
because you can actually take it in you
know I first time I flew I was so young
that I don't ever have that like oh this
is what it looks like from the [ __ ]
air you'll be fine
all right William I've been dating my
girls this is last one and then I get I
got to get off my day here of doing
absolutely nothing
well Yin I William I've been dating my
girl for a few years now and everything
started out great however over the
course of the past few months I've
noticed a sudden change in her behavior
and was wondering if you dealt with
anything like this before
yeah she's either using drugs or [ __ ]
someone else or she's depressed [ __ ]
with you let me read the rest of this
basically when we hang out lately she
just won't stop asking questions she may
ask what are you listening to I might
say the Bill burr podcast then she will
ask why I don't know because I enjoy it
he says then she will follow it up with
why don't you listen to the radio or
another podcast and down the rabbit hole
it goes oh I don't like this person
already the thing is these questions are
non-stop and so subjective it got to the
point where I straight-up asked her if
she was trolling me and she denied it
everything else in relationship is going
well so I'm not sure what to do I've
talked to her and told her she asked too
many questions
she then turns around on me and says I
never want to talk to her any oh she
turns it turns it around on me and says
that I never want to talk to her anymore
that's not talking it's just asking a
bunch of [ __ ] question so what should
I do break up with her just answer the
questions what would you do bill why is
your name bill anyways why not Dave huh
why isn't it Dave bill why aren't you
answering me bill don't want to talk
anymore why is the podcast an hour
anyways why not an hour 10 or 50 minutes
hon bill yeah all right dude I just
walked in your shoes there yeah yeah I
would break up with her
I break up with them I do maybe a but if
you really like her I give it one last
chance and just be like just tell her
you're driving me [ __ ] insane and
yeah you're just you're driving me
[ __ ] insane I like everything about
you but that and if my life with you is
going to be that I'm going to leave okay
like I'm the answer dude I don't know
how people change changing yourself who
the [ __ ] you are is really difficult so
hopefully it'll work out with you so
that's that's what I would do I would
just say listen I like everything but
that everything about you is great
except for that but that is so [ __ ]
horrific this is going to walk out that
[ __ ] door if you don't cut it up
that's it that's it if I could redo my
whole dating life it would have been
[ __ ] communicating instead of just
being like well I'm going out getting
shit-faced what was wrong yesterday
nothing I'm sorry and then you don't
[ __ ] work it out hey you work it out
okay all right that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on ya on Thursday thank you to
everybody who's been listening to the
podcast and obviously I'm beyond excited
to do this tour starting uhh oh my god
the thirty-first not starts the 30th
doesn't the [ __ ] out of here
oh my show is until the 31st well what
do you know I'll have an X today they're
in here and all right here it is in case
you're listening Dublin Ireland Belfast
then Galway then Bristol UK Manchester
UK I probably should say two dates July
31st I'm in Dublin August 1st I'm in
Belfast August 2nd Galway then I go over
to England I'm in Bristol on the 3rd and
on the 4th I'm in Manchester you know
what's in between Bristol and Manchester
John Bonham's grave site if I have time
I'm going to pay my respects I'm not
going to do a [ __ ] selfie like a
douche just going to pay my respects if
I at the time
August 6 5th and 6th I'm in London
England
August 7th in Amsterdam August 8th I
mean Edinboro for two-shoes August 9th
I'm in Edinboro for two more shows the
[ __ ] doing all right there
August 11th no wait a minute yeah I did
say Amsterdam right on August 7th August
11th I'm in Cologne Germany and then
August 12th I'm in Antwerp Belgium and
then August 27th I'm in Reno Nevada back
in the USA alright everybody thank you
for listening and thank you to everybody
overseas who's been dot buying tickets I
can't wait to come over there and make
you laugh all right go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Thursday